peut-elle redescendre dans l'est de
l'ukraine emmanuel macron poursuit sa
tournée diplomatique auprès des
différents acteurs de cette crise il est
attendu à kiev dans les toutes
prochaines heures pour une rencontre
avec volodymyr zelensky le président
français lui fera part de la longue
discussion de la veille avec vladimir
poutine au kremlin les deux hommes se
sont entretenus pendant plus de cinq
heures avant de tenir une conférence de
presse dans la soirée on va revenir sur
cette rencontre en compagnie d'hélène à
vau-l'eau chine à moscou bonjour lna
est-ce qu emmanuel macron a pu obtenir
des engagements de la part de vladimir
poutine
bien le kremlin disent ne pas s'attendre
à des avancées décisives à des percées
décisives à l'issue de cette rencontre
emmanuel macron non plus à ils s'en sont
tenus c'était a de fait il n'y a pas eu
de grosse avancée concrète ni pour
résoudre cette crise autour de l'ukraine
ni sur l'impasse russie otan la france
aurait tout juste obtenu des femmes ces
fameux signe de désescalade de la part
de bhl a dit me à poutine dont parlait
emmanuel macron jeudi aurait parce que
les deux présidents n'ont pas dit un mot
lors de la conférence de presse n'ont
pas évoqué publiquement c'est l'elysée
qui l'a fait savoir ensuite et a dit que
blazy maire poutine se seraient engagés
à ne pas entamer de nouvelles manoeuvres
militaires que celles qui sont déjà en
cours et à retirer ses troupes de
biélorussie à l'issue des exercices qui
sont a prévu sur ce territoire aux
frontières du craignait entre le 10 et
le 20 février donc dans le contexte
actuel c'est déjà quelque chose mais pas
d'autres avancées concrètes emmanuel
macron a fait des propositions sur
lesquelles il ya des termes de
convergence entre la france et la russie
selon ses termes vladimir poutine a
confirmé que selon lui ces propositions
pouvait servir de base aux étapes
suivantes alors de quelle proposition
s'agit-il elles seront elles suffisantes
pour parvenir finalement à ce fameux
compromis bien cela reste pour l'heure
un mystère
on en saura peut-être plus dans les
prochaines heures lna le ballet
diplomatique est loin d'être terminée
pour les différents acteurs de cette
crise
mais effectivement vous lisez donc
emmanuel macron on va ce matin kiev pour
rendre compte de cet entretien avec
vladimir poutine au président ukrainien
il ira ensuite sans doute à b avant de
rentrer à paris pour rencontrer le
chancelier allemand olaf scholz et le
président polonais angelo da la semaine
prochaine c'est olaf scholz qui sera à
moscou pour rencontrer à son tour
vladimir poutine un effort cette fois du
président russe de dialoguer avec les
européens plutôt qu'avec les états unis
qui jusqu'à présent était son
interlocuteur privilégié sur ces fameux
dossier de sécurité européenne et
notamment de guerre en ukraine
mais les états unis et l'otan ont opposé
une fin de non recevoir aux exigences de
vladimir poutine qui sont que les
américains retirent leurs troupes de
europe de l'est et leur matériel
militaire et que l'otan s'engage à ne
pas à s'élargir plus avant en europe de
l'est et à ne pas intégrer notamment
l'ukraine donc ça c'est dans l'impasse 1
du point du côté des américains et de
l'otan donc vladimir poutine fait des
efforts pour relancer ce fameux format
10 de normandie en plus en la france
l'allemagne l'ukraine et la russie au
point mort depuis 2019 pour tenter de
mettre en place ces fameux accords de
minsk qui sont qui doivent depuis 2015
servir de base à une sortie de conflit
en ukraine mais qui sont lettre morte
depuis un moment donc il y à il y aura
cet effort les conseillers en tous cas
du groupe de normandie vont se réunir à
nouveau ils se sont réunis à paris il ya
deux semaines pour tenter d'organiser
dans un futur visible dans un futur
proche ce fameux sommet au format de
normandie entre ses chefs d'état et les
nains volochine depuis moscou pour
france24 merci beaucoup lna